I'm a little worse for wear so let's
judge what people wore it's that time of
year again when people basically we're
just couches to a red carpet event and
we call it the Met Gala
every year the McCullough has a theme to
it last year was fashion in the age of
technology this year it's ray
kohaku beau comme des Garcons actually
reading directly from an article right
Kawakubo has a fashion label called
comme des Garcons French for like boys
this designer invites us to rethink
fashion as a site of content creation
recreation she has defined the
aesthetics of our time okay so that's
the theme for this year's Met Gala
fashion event extravaganza let's review
what people were I know I went on
Twitter and asked you guys to send me
some of your favorite looks from the Met
Gala so these are all sourced by you I
hope you're happy here when he brought
his hair his hair
um okay Jaden Smith some would say he's
an innovator a revolutionary or this is
commitment I've gone to events where
I've brought a bag that was kind of
cumbersome and I've been like gosh this
is going to be annoying to carry for the
rest of the night but he brought his
dreadlocks and he seemingly gonna carry
them for the rest of the night I mean
where else you worked how do you put
where do you put those you coat check
them oh yeah yeah oh my god this oh god
I just love the dais so much parents on
your dress and your hair and your skin
if this is like Pirates of the Caribbean
but like pirates I care about being
friends with you would you like please
my friends you look beautiful
Rihanna yep yep yeah mm-hmm you know
it's a good day for fashion when the
theme of your look is how can I be most
uncomfortable you guys know that I think
Briana is one of the greatest comedians
of our time and this just proves it have
you ever been vacuuming and it also new
vacuum just stops and it locks up
because something's caught in the tubes
and you open up the vacuum and to pull
out this thing that's going like
I wrapped all around it and it ends up
being the thing that Rihanna wears to
the Met Gala is Julie because draw me
like one of your french girls meme
hasn't gotten enough attention recently
and did he just want to make sure that
we were all still thinking about that
Titanic car Adele Jones your mom's deaf
Cara Delevingne Karen deviled egg god I
love how serious everyone's like you
know you you know you know you know like
you know this is very very Terminator
chic
that's cute can you carry this
yeah absolutely why not I think maybe
the theme I'm misinterpreting I don't
speak French but I think the theme might
be this is what you pull out of your
vacuum and there's beauty and everything
and maybe that's the lesson here we call
mais in the weekend they look
overcompensating ly happy this looks
super cute it looks like they're going
to prom and it looks like Selena Gomez
just like ant then also is a makeup
artist was like let me be your makeup
we're going to do it awesome and then
she kind of you know should have stayed
a librarian Priyanka Chopra is vector
gadget Wow
this is a trench coat that is genuinely
the signs of a trench where in the world
is Carmen Sandiego she's at the fabric
store I'm some more material for her
train I really like that if you were a
private eye you would not get much
investigating done because that the
train that takes a lot of engineers to
get to the station
Kerry Washington this looks like a very
very cool quilt it's icing and like Pier
one Imports combined into one store they
sell something like this Blake Lively
Wow I actually really like this click
the most fashionable chain now let's
ever seen I feel steam silky in certain
Punk I don't understand the theme but I
like this ensemble this looks like my
brother was in a punk ska vouchers and
band in high schools like wet dream
girlfriend concept idea some went to the
army supply store and sex it for trial
and his wife and oh my god I love furro
furro phase is just looking at the
photographer's thinking are we still
getting away with this nonsense so we're
going I got that hat through an event
can we get this thing to a little bit
I'm sure it makes so much sense but I
can't make sense of it very clearly soon
looks like the spaciest and at the
wedding you look great girl you always
look good oh my gosh yeah yeah big time
I think this is just what nikki minaj
wears on a tuesday this is on theme what
is 50 quickly Hadid super awesome
impression of that lamp from a Christmas
story eighties streetwalker meets
eighties businesswoman hybrid and that's
the same right is that the same worth to
see the Olsen twins are there and now I
have no hour they the theme kendall
Jenner
okay who is that the see Ella Roberts
looks like she found someone pink stole
on the ground outside the Met Gala and
is very concerned about not knowing who
it blush I think the theme is use
confusion very very what's up yeah okay
I've ever actually bought gold streamers
already streamers from Party City and
then um
suck them up in a vacuum okay there you
go there is my assessment of the Met
Ball of fashions for 2017 let me know
who your favorite look was in the
comments down below and give this video
a thumbs up if you like these fashion
videos I like making fashion reviews and
if you like then that makes me like them
even more also subscribe to this youtube
channel because I make videos Monday
Wednesday and Friday sometimes
that I don't know